why does nature prefer spherical shapes
well it doesn't always I mean the sea
tends to be flattish about this for idle
and and the earth is very large but I
think it's more dependent on what forces
are involved so if you're on a very
large scale gravitational forces pull
the Sun into a spheroidal structure on
the small scale droplets form began what
pulls them being is surface tension
effects so that when that strong a
sphere is the i guess the has the
smaller surface area for given volume so
that's what is maximized so under those
extremes it becomes a sort of spheroidal
structure in the case of graphite these
are flat sheets but these are locked
into the source of situation they were
in the tars from which they were
produced and so the answer is in those
cases where it does prefer prefer royal
structures and the forces of nature of
surface tension gravitational forces act
two forms here in the case of the son of
course they're pulling inwards that's
the best I can do what's a bad question
that's from GV shriya of Bangalore